um i just want to talk about green
technology very quickly we haven't got
long um days
where do you stand on this is it the
future to to solving the climate crisis
uh the answer short answer is no
i'm not anti-technology i think there is
a space for technology in the solution
that we make to solve the climate crisis
however there needs to be an awareness
of we have to solve this by the roots
and the roots is based on exploitation
and based on exploitation of people but
then also planet as well this is an
issue that stems from behavior you know
and the only way that we can really
solve this is by looking at this but
then there's also the other hand of
the best carbon sequester in the world
is our earth our earth has been doing it
before humans even existed uh this is
something that i think we have to have
some like humbleness and humility around
as we have the technology the
technologies the earth how can we help
the earth heal for you know the earth to
be able to manage its own ecosystem and
we can use green technology in the way
too to get there however we can't depend
on it because a lot of these
technologies
bring up a lot of social justice issues
but then also they're extremely unproven
on the mass scale that are needed to
uphold the current structures of society
and
not enough conversations being had about
that okay and baroness worthington just
just briefly if you would
do you agree with daisy's assessment
oh i wish i could unfortunately
nature is not on our side right you just
saw this what's happening in north
america at the moment we we've we've
basically dabbled with the global
physics and it's going to come back and
bite us i'm afraid so earth earth will
look after earth it won't necessarily
look after humans and we will need all
of our ingenuity to basically help
ourselves get back to stable climate so
i wouldn't rule anything out and i think
we have got to start building clean
technology at scale whilst at the same
time helping nature to get back to
something more normal but we're going
into a really big period of consequences
and it's going to be hard
you